when I was 13 years old I lost my
hearing when I got the mumps as you can
imagine this makes it difficult to
communicate with people when I met my
future wife she was able to communicate
with me only by spelling out letters on
my hand a month later we met again and I
found out that she had taught herself
yeah off the bat this was a successful
strategy because been married no from
the 18 years
last fall Ted had come to my office to
tell me about an idea that he had for
adapting Skype translator to a scenario
that would actually be useful to him
Ted being deaf can't make calls over
Skype but with Skype translator because
it produces transcripts he could
actually read the response back from
someone so we sat down and talked about
it for a little bit and there were some
pieces missing in Skype translators so
we needed to actually do something to
make it more appropriate for that
scenario
Ted Hart is requesting an automatically
translated call I usually need to have
an ASL interpreter for my meetings at
work it means it really start to be
planned in advance and sometimes this
isn't always possible it doesn't replace
an ASL interpreter but it gives me a lot
of other options one carry to the last
minute
although these features were really
impactful for Ted in his work life what
really hit me was the realization that
there was a big impact on his personal
life I realized that using Skype
translator I could call my wife directly
for the first time there our relay
services that you can use but they are
inconvenient and require our time to
initiate the call with Skype translator
I just read the transcript I understand
what she is saying it's really cool that
24 euros after she learned sign language
and trim I brought I can take a more
full step into hers so I was sitting
back thinking about this and looking at
it and realizing the impact that this
could have for me for people here at
Microsoft and for our customers for
people with deafness with
hard-of-hearing all over the world
technology has that power it can empower
people to do things and make things
easier it's available now download it
give it a try and help us to make this a
better and better product